um good afternoon everyone
um
i'm happy to be with us and once again i
want to welcome all participants to this
only
omics research symbol with the automatic
focus
on bioinformatics and data science
research and training
uh beginning with a session by the
mislogic asia i have no doubt that the
entire symposium would be an enriching
and stimulating um scientific discourse
over this two days period
so moving on here within the omislogic
africa section
we will in the next uh an hour and a
half be looking at the immunologic
africa programs and the scope of
bioinformatics training within the
african continent in the past 12 months
we will equally be taking two important
keynote presentations by two new table
scholars of refute um firstly is uh
professor kintudy
sorry akindeva bhattandi who will be
doing justice to the topic advancing
biomedical research with omix data and
computational biology in africa i'm
talking from insights from our
researches and then that will be
followed by dr mariana dbu who will be
speaking on opportunities for
bioinformatics and computational
approaches in scientific research in
africa and importantly we will be taking
on a panel session afterwards to discuss
on bioinformatics education training and
research
in africa uh before then let me uh
quickly
um give an overview of the introduction
on omislogic africa programs
and which uh and as well as partnerships
and some of the outcomes we've achieved
in the past um um 12 months so moving on
allow me to introduce myself
um my name is adekunya
i'm a faculty unicity
university in nigeria and i'm an
associate with medical laboratory
science council of nigeria i'm also a
member i'm facilitator with prime
biotech incorporated
c and troubles as the program director
for mislogic africa and eureka
i am therefore pleased to introduce you
all to miss logic africa programs during
the next
and 10 minutes
equally um permit me to quickly
acknowledge here the omis logic africa
and working hard to advance the omis
omislogic training across
africa
so the omislogic sets of bioinformatics
and big data analysis training programs
of the prime biotech incorporated which
has been globally proven by peer reviews
and curriculum experts in partnering
stations is being eventually explored in
closing the needed gaps
with regards to bioinformatics education
and training
globally
of course this is of great importance
for us here in africa in terms of
building
these scientific capacities among
students
researchers young scholars young
professionals
and faculties across the
african continent
and so um the postulation rather um with
omisologic africa that is anchored by
eureka is that by increasingly advancing
the knowledge of bioinformatics and in
its use in obtaining scientific insights
from sequence data there will be a
significant growth and development of
the bioinformatics community here in
africa and its considerable implications
for translational science from
understanding of gene functions
as well as its ruling biology
agricultural medicine means just um a
variety of feeds uh for addressing
challenges that are peculiar to the
population here within the continent and
so the goal of homeless loyalty programs
therefore is to provide this training in
bioinformatics
by enabling students clinicians and
faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
that is guided by mentors and peer
examples and so the omis logic programs
boost of everything the participant
needs to get started and grow in the
bioinformatics and big data analysis
space for scientific research and
practice
our programs combine online interactive
sections and self-guided study materials
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience proven to have been
very effective in our well-known and
respected mixed logic bioinformatics and
training programs so um while the
growing interest in bioinformatics and
big data analysis continues to grow here
in africa many are still far from being
able to gain this key set for
utilization in their scientific research
um
as well as practice but we are glad that
we do miss logic africa training
programs of primeval 10 corporate these
gaps are being breached for students
faculties and researchers across the
african continent and so i'd like to
quickly share
here a few of such programs which over
the course of the past 12 months we have
organized um you know to bring
bioinformatics training with project
guided learning and resources to a
cross-section of participants across
you know the continent ranging from
beginners and students many of whom are
new to bioinformatics to
postgraduates as well as researchers and
faculties wanting to develop skills and
research capacity to explore the world
of umic sciences and using
bioinformatics and big data analysis to
answer research questions so um this
high training of course includes data
science for biologists introduction to
bioinformatics
as well as
with bioinformatics and computational
biology and also we've gone into
bioinformatics for biomedical drug
discovery these are some of the programs
we've run lately
and equally
at least test program is the umix logic
training for students and researchers
which is a basic bioinformatics
introductory workshop and i was recently
concluded and this
program actually had over 200
participants who participated and gained
the requisite skill to get introduced
and to get introduced into the
bioinformatics space
equally we recently conducted homicide
genomics workshop
which we just concluded and it's amazing
the outcome we got from these programs
as we have currently a number of
participants moving on currently into
our research fellowship program so this
training is essentially prepares these
participants and some of the training
program participants
who have gone from being beginners in
bioinformatics to learning requisite
skill sets that they can apply into
their own personal research and practice
um include stem multi um um some of the
um you know
of the things that these participants
have learned and equally acquired a
number of expertise in a cross section
of um
domains
learning domains on our learning
platform equally we have ubisola a
pharmaceutical microbiologist who has
seen her practice on application of keep
informatics concept in her practice
significantly um enhanced and um in
addition to that we have jason lee
florida from cameroon who now sees
ourselves
well prepared to take on our research
and you know journey into the marine
biology studies space leveraging on kids
cases from our mixed logic um
informatics trainings
so surface to say that and we have also
forged notable partnerships with
institutions towards integrating our
hands-on
mentor-driven globally proven training
methods and resources into university
education across africa
both at undergraduate as well as
postgraduate levels and just to help
scale rapidly the growth our capacity of
bioinformatics researches and
you know um across the continent and so
few of such notable partnerships include
you know partners we listed university
in nigeria
we also have a partnership with
crescent university as well as ocean
state university and most most
much recently we had a working
relationship in with
university of yandee that is in cameroon
similarly mislogic africa team has
participated at notable regional
scientific workshops uh such as the
nigerian bioinformatics and genomics
network where we had a poster
presentation on the topic experimenting
with
21st century e-learning design for
bridging bioinformatics education gaps
in africa a test case with mislogic
activity rubrics
and moving along i'd like to quickly
mention our next
training program that is around the
corner uh which is another introductory
bioinformatics workshop abused to take
place between the 7th and 13th of
september
it's an introductory
beginner level workshop and the goal is
to bring a number of participants into
the
umix logic as well as bioinformatics and
big data science skills and knowledge
and space and so this program will be
happening soon
and shortly after that we also intend to
run another omics logic meta genomics
workshop and uh i will encourage
participants to please stay on the
lookout for these programs
so moving on um in conclusion um the
african continent uh has been regarded
as the crowd of modern humans and also
the african germans known to uh you know
contain more genetic variations than
those from another continent um across
the globe um thus it presents a reachful
focus for scientific studies
bioinformatics has become definitely an
indispensable tool for management of
this hugely generated data in modern
biology medicine and related feeds
however infrastructure regards and other
challenges with educational systems
within continent remains a cost for
concern hence the need for innovative
approach to advancing performance
education and training across africa and
of course comics logic programs of the
primavera technology occupies a
strategic role in scaling the
bioinformatics education and training
needs um for today as well as um you
know in the
in the future to call and so we hope to
continue to play a significant role in
this space